上课了啊，同学们。
这次真的是好久不见，所以呢先跟大家说声抱歉，确实时间有点长了。这次。
咱们这个课开始的时候是日更，我坚持日更了好几天。
然后呢变成了粥梗。
沦落到现在成了月羹。
眼看从洗面奶变成护舒宝了。
频率不能再低了，再低变成春晚了是吧？那就不像话了。有些同学确实也留言给我说，老师是不是课程结束了？
不会结束吗？我不是说了吗？我们一直更啊，只要有时间就更。
咱们这个课是实战课。
所以你们得理解我，我天天在实战，我在上班呀，我在工作，我有很多剧本要写剧组的工作要做，天天在工作在一线。
嗯，但是这样也有好处啊，同学们，我在一线中发现了问题。
吸取的养分，我不是回头就来传授给你们了吗？
所以大家要有耐心。
对吧咱们的教学计划呢。
确实目前来说就是没有计划了，已经因为有计划了呢。
都讲的差不多了。到后面呢我们就是。
看到有什么新的问题，有什么新的想法就及时的跟大家分享，好不好？
这个嗯。
后面我还是尽量吧尽量还是保持一两周更一节课。
好不好？
但是同学们也不用完全等我。
因为这个我说过啊，编剧学习啊是个长期的过程。
你说他是个终身的事业都都不过分，对不对？你现在就可以写了。你如果前面的课程已经看熟练了，掌握好了。
你完全可以开始写。
完全可以开始写。对了，我们有很多同学现在就已经开始写了嘛，有很多成果呀，咱这个月虽然没有更新课程，但是教学工作并不是完全没有成果。
有很大的成果。可以说。
这个月我们搞了一个实验班。
就啥叫实验班呢？就是通过两次考试，我们考试了两回，通过两次考试。
选选拔出一些同学进入了一个实验班。
然后这个实验班呢就基本上都是。
要么有过作品的。
已经入行了，要么呢是有写作能力，有写作基础的。
搞了这么一个实验班。
为啥要搞这么一个班呢？
是因为我这个课上了这几个月之后呢。
呃，不光是有了很多同学，很多学生。
也有很多同行也也也看了这个课了。
有好几家公司，包括我们单位都跟我说，应该把这个。
学的比较好的。
比较有天赋的这种同学。
这个这个招到公司来。
或者给公司写剧本。
反正是要么合作，要么入职。
所以呢咱们就是开始。
呃，选拔这个实验班，然后在实验班里面。
呃，帮同学呃牵线搭桥，有的呢把作品卖掉，有的呢就给他们牵线找工作。
现在已经有。
四个同学吧。
四个同学已经这个这个在写剧本了，或者是在上班了。
诶。
有两个还是我的同事也天天跟我一块儿上班。
我觉得这挺好的啊，相当于把咱们这个课啊打通了，你知道吧？相当于咋把这这个这个这个流程打通了，是吧？你上课，然后一节一节上，然后考试选拔，然后入职入行。
之前不是还有很多同学问我说，哎呀，老师，你教我们这个这个课，那我们怎么入行呢？我们在一个小县城，你看哎，现在不就打通了吗？
这其实是个良心循环啊，同学们。
我们继续这么搞的话，哎，我们前线送出去的那些同学，如果争气，对吧？如果给咱们争脸。
写的剧本也不错，或者是在工作岗位发发挥的很好。那人家用人单位会继续从我们这要人，是不是？
这这这打通了。
这是个大好事儿啊。
而且有个同学到我们单位去面试，那简历我还看到了，给我笑得要命。毕业院校直接写了一个查理的编剧课7班。
你挺骄傲的是吧？
万一不是我面试怎么办？我知道你是想溜须拍马一下，对吧？他万一不是我面试怎么办？不要瞎搞啊。
但是还是很开心啊还是很开心。
这个。
陆续有同学对吧？
但是入行了，或者是说进入正轨了。
我们这个课程有成果，这是非常开心的一件事情。正能量非常正能量。
然后呢，我们这个选拔这个七班啊是通过考试。
考了两回，有些同学呢没有机会参加考试，或者是考了之后没考上，也不要灰心。我们后面再继续嘛，对不对？但是你不要着急。
因为啥呢？
嗯。
考试这个玩意儿吧。
考客观题，因为咱们不是不是在身边考，在线上考试嘛？考客观题大家相当于就是开卷考试嘛，所以客观题没什么好考的。
就只能考主观题。考主观题呢。
确实是比较能看出水平，但是苦了我了呀，同学们。
我出一套出一套主观题，考一次，我就得出一套新题，因为漏题了嘛。
然后呢，大家答几千字交上来，每次考试100多个考生，我们每次考试发100多个考号啊，不是全体。我们现在一共有10个自然班，5000多个学生，不可能5000多个学生都考，每次发100多个考号，这100多份卷子。
每份卷子几千字，大几千字。
而且还附件，还有他们的作品。
你知道我得看多长时间，我光批卷子批三四天。
所以咱们这个这个考试呀。
呃，也没有办法。
所有同学都考也没有办法密度很大，不可能今年考了，明天又考，对吧？那我我受不了呀，是不是？
这个所以希望同学们理解一下，不要着急，你先写，你只要写的东西好，我肯定想办法帮你们这个牵线搭桥，对不对？
这个这个事情就是。
哎，怎么说呢？
通过上这个课啊，也确实是体会很多。开始同学们都是很感恩的。
我跟你说，同学们一开始的时候都是很感恩的说啊老师免费课上的这么好，上的这么用心。我们真的老师我们白嫖你，我们真的非常感恩感恩的心。
然后结果发现我开始招实验班了之后，而且给实验班的人介绍工作了以后，有些同学就不干了。说老师我写的也挺好的呀，为什么没有推荐我呢？
我说你感到心哪去了，是不是别闹啊别闹，慢慢来啊。
慢慢来好，废话不多说了啊，嗯呃再说几句再说几句废话。就关于这个这个考试，因为我们每次考的题考一遍就泄题了，所以呢这这个也没有什么好保密的。
嗯。
有兴趣考的同学都可以看看之前的考卷，看看我们考的考些什么。你你也心里先有点数。然后我针对错的比较多的题，或者是。
拿的不理想的几个题吧，讲一讲吧。因为有好多同学问我。
嗯。
我们考的都是些主观题啊，比如说那个题。
有这么一个题，说爸爸。
接。
女儿。
放学。
爸爸接女儿放学。
题面是什么呢？给这个事件。
增加烈度。
增加力度。
这个题呢。
有一半同学左右嗯能得满分的。
就是还可以吧，但是也有同学答的不好，我们来讲一下。
首先什么叫列读啊？因为这个事情啊是个非常生活的事情，平平无奇，对吧？
在剧本中，如果需要有这么一件事情，你是要给他增加烈度的。
我们现在不考虑人设，不考虑。
剧本的具体情况，故事背景不考虑。
就考虑单个事件来增加力度。
都有哪些方方向呢？我们说挺多的，方向挺多的。
比如说对手。
嗯，代价对吧？或者是奖励。
然后阻力。
这些时间锁。
这些方面都可以增加这个事件的烈度。比如说对手。
你去接你女儿放学，西松平常。
的一件事儿。那如果加一个对手呢？
有人想要绑架你女儿啊。
有人想要去学校绑架你女儿。
所以你才着急，赶紧去学校把你女儿接回来。
跟绑匪抢时间呢。
这不就是对手吗？
这不就有对手了吗？
那么。
接不到的代价，不就是女儿。
命都保住了吗？
对不对？
然后。
这个这个。
奖励。
也可以有呀。比如说。
你是个这个这个离婚了。
女儿跟妈妈。
跟前期。
然后呢，这个周末呢，你想带女儿。
这个这个。
呃，去玩一玩。
过一个这个这个。
愉快的周末。
然后呢，你前妻不太愿意让女儿跟你，然后我跟你说，那你周五放学，你去接女儿，你你你按时去接女儿，女儿就跟你过周末。
你不接到女儿，我要带女儿出国了，我找了一个外国男朋友。
哎，你是不是要抓紧时间跟你女儿沟通感情，劝你女儿别跟那个后爸走呀，咱在中国多好啊。
你看这个奖励大不大，一瞬间就有奖励了。
这就是从奖励的角度。
阻力的角度呢，比如说。
车坏了。
堵车了，撞车了，这不都是阻力吗？
这不都是独立吗？
是吧时间锁也很常用啊，来不及了呀，说好的几点，现在是几点，路程是需要多长时间？时间锁有了时间锁以后，这些东西全部会加强。
全部更。
着急了呀。
对不对？
我们说你看这就是从方方面面都可以增加这个事件的烈度。这个我们之前练习过的，好吧。
当然还有啊，你看我们说阻力阻力有三种，环境的阻力，对手的阻力，还有一种是自己的阻力啊，自身的阻力呀，你也可以用呀。我们说的影视作品有出现过的，老爸着急忙慌去接女儿哇历经艰险，冲破所有的对手代驾奖励阻力时间索。光咣去了以后一看哎。
嗯，没有，为什么？
走错学校了。
你都不知道你女儿在哪上学。
你还好意思去接，你还好意思不让人出国，你女儿都上初中了，你还去小学接人家。
这就是你自己带来的阻力，你自己本身就不合格。
这不光是阻力，还能把你的人设做出来呀，还能把这个爸爸的人设做出来。你确实对女儿有亏欠，对不对？
你看这就是一个简单事件，增加烈度，方方面面都可以做，对吧？你随便写个几方面，哎，这个题我就给你满分了，就这么简单。
没有那么复杂。
再说一个大家基本上都折了的题吧。
而且我发现这类题啊，每次考试基本上都是全军覆没，就就是没有人得满分。
而且普遍得分。
太低了，就是看图说话的题。
第一次考的试也考过，第二次考试又考了一张图。
是一张什么图呢？那后期的同学给我放一下这张图啊，大家就看一下这张图。
洗碗槽里一堆脏碗。
然后题面是什么呢？给这张图配旁白要求是什么呢？感人至深的旁白。
感人至深的旁白。
有很多同学马上就蒙圈了。
有的同学甚至写了根本就不是旁白。
首先我们说啥是旁白？旁白就是你看你这个这个这个影视剧里面或者是电影里面。
有个。
话外音有个声音在在读，往往是像诗一样的，或者是教代一些背景一样的东西，对不对？
那个玩意儿就是旁白啊。
那你给这张图写一段感人至深的旁白。
我们说怎么写呢？
有同学问我说，老师，你如果是你你怎么写？
我给他举了个例子。
我说你可以配这样一段旁白。
一个。
女人的声音。
这么说。
你说。
结婚后。
碗泥洗。
家务你做。
你骗了我。
你说。
你会一直照顾我。
你骗了我。
你说。
你会永远跟我在一块，永远不分开。
你骗了我。
你说。
这次抗洪抢险。
你是连长，你必须得去，但你一定会活着回来。
你又骗了我。
这样不就。
感人了吗？
不就把这个碗没有洗的碗一槽子脏碗配就段旁白不就有故事了吗？
就有情感嘛。
这样。
就可以了。
有很多同学得分了。
但是呢。
没有得满分，为什么呢？因为有很多同学有一定的经验的时候啊，他知道这个情况下必须要死人。
就说有人死掉。
是比较可以感人的。
然后他们就想的是比如说。
前一直是奶奶洗碗，对吧？现在洗碗的人不在。
我就给了分了，但是没有给满分，为什么呢？
低太直白。
第二呢。
我说这句话下面可应该可能会有弹幕喷我暴击我。
奶奶是自然死亡。
生老病死。
当然难过。
但是他的力量没有一个年轻的生命，因为抗抢险牺牲了来的强。
明白这个意思吧？
所以说啊。
我们编剧确实挺无情的啊。
多用点技巧。
多想想办法，好吧，这些题呀都没有那么难。
主观题啊也没有那么难。
下次考试肯定要换题的，但是思路你们可以先了解一下。
哎，那我们就接着上今天的课。
今天课讲点什么呢？
今天的课啊灵感来源于我也是跟同学们一块看片儿。
前几天我们一块看。
失之愈合的电影。
我相信很多这个这个这个从业者爱好者都非常喜欢失之愈合，确实很很火。文艺青年的最爱很火，我也很喜欢啊，我也很喜欢，因为它确实很细腻，做的作品确实很。
很柔和，很细腻，也很有力量。
然后有些同学呢就给我下套，就说老师这。
看我说好看呀，你喜欢失之一合吗？我说我喜欢呀。
然后他们就开始老师，哼哼，但是失之愈合的电影。
他的故事不符合你的要求哦。
和你说的很多地方都不匹配呀。
怎么回事嘞？
是不是你讲错了，你有时候是不是也别那么绝对呀？
是不是也允许这样的作品呀？
就问我这个问题。
哎。
同学们，你们太幼稚了。
我出来混，我出来讲课，我难道怕这样的问题吗？你以为我没遇到过吗？
你们太幼稚了。
我当然喜欢失之欲合，我当然知道这样作品可以存在。同学们当然喜欢，当然人家可以存在，当然合理。
但问题是什么呢？
我讲的是编剧课呀，我们培养的是编剧呀，是吃愈合的作品要编剧吗？
人家要你写啊。
人家全都是自己写的呀。
那叫什么电影啊？那叫什么作品啊？
那叫作者电影。
人家自己写自己拍，自己玩，爱咋弄咋弄。
就是这样子，那样作品是不需要编剧的。
我就马上想起有个同学写了一个东西，就写了一个东西很。
就很水。
很水的一个东西。然后我说你这个东西就很水呀。
然后他反驳我，他说老师，我这个东西。
很生活呀。
如果找一个好的导演再配一个好的演员，我这个作品肯定挺好看的呀。
但问题是凭什么呀？
凭什么很水的一个东西要给你配一个好的导演，一个好的演员呢？
如果配给你配一个失之愈合去导阿布宽去演，那他找一份报纸照着拍，也不愿拿你这个剧本拍呀。
是不是啊？是这个问题呀？
所以说。
作者的电影不是你。
琢磨了事儿，不是你能比的。
这就像什么啊？我以前无数次比喻说。
拍戏像做菜，对吧？假设拍一个电影像试做一道菜，那么。
导演是厨师，编剧是。
配菜的你给厨师配菜，配原料。
你作为一个配菜员。
你的基本素养就是要弄到好的食材。
你不能说哈给你根黄瓜。
牛逼的厨师，一根黄瓜也能做的很很很好，也也能登大雅之堂。你如果说这种话，那你就别干这个活了。而且他如果真的打算把一根黄瓜做的雕龙画凤登上大雅之堂，他根本不要配菜员。
他自己带一根黄瓜不好吗？是不是？所以说咱们不能这么去去考虑问题。咱们作为编剧就研究我们分内的事，就研究怎么写一个有烈度的故事，有强度的故事，商业的故事，好看的故事。
作者电影呢人家是自编自导。
自己找钱，甚至拿钱养，拿钱烧，拿钱砸。
导演是富养出来的。
我跟你说，导演跟编剧最大的区别啊，导演是富养出来的，他人生前几部作品你肯定要亏钱嘛，因为老想自我表达，就赔钱，先坑几个投资人，然后呢自己牛逼起来了富养。
你知道吧？编剧是穷养出来的。
编剧的人生前几部作品拿不到片酬，或者给人当写手，连名都不数，就穷养出来了。
所以你不要老去比这个攀比人家。
那个导演你明白我意思吗？人家爱表达什么表达什么，人家爱自我就自我跟你没有关系，你得吃饭。
是这么个意思，好吧，所以以后大家不要去攀比这种片子，攀比失之愈合。
人家牛逼。
人家能找到钱。
对吧人家爱咋拍照？
是这个意思。
所以别别别别考虑这个问题，我们继续我们的路子。
商业片好看的片子。
观众片子拍给观众看的片子。
这是我们要做的事情。
所以今天呢。
借着上次同学跟我讨论的这个这个问题，就是关于如何欣赏一个。
作品从一个作品中能学到什么？其实呢就是你们常说的拉片编剧拉片。我之前说过啊，我之前说过我不喜欢讲拉片，我不喜欢把一部片子从头到尾每一场给你拉一遍，告诉你为什么牛逼，那浪费时间你自己也能拉。但是我发现有些同学呢拉片的时候啊。
没有重点。
抓不到精髓。所以这节课我简单给大家说一下，我在看一个片子的时候，我在拉片的时候，我从人家那里能。
学到点什么？好吧，这个这节课我们就探讨一下关于编剧怎么拉片的问题。
编剧拉片的问题啊，我们今天还是照例找一个大商业片作为这个这个这个例子，大家一起研究一下，我给大家找了一个片子。
麻烦了。
阿凡达。
阿凡达可是大唱蝇片啊。
大上一篇零几年的吧啊。
在那个年代，哎，阿凡达开创了好几个技术方面的这个这个这个先河。
比如说那个虚拟摄影棚。
然后动作捕捉。
啊，就那个那个小人弄一身球，哈动作捕捉，那是人家发明的。
还有呢就是那个这个这个3D。
现在大家都看3D电影，人家先开始的，人家第一个，对不对？
所以说这个片子不不管是从商业上还是从技术上，都是一个非常牛逼的划时代的片子。
但是有很多同学呢老说喜欢阿凡达，喜欢阿凡达，看不明白，或者是抓不到重点。今天我就给大家分析一下这个阿凡达，我们从编剧的角度我们能学到什么？
首先我们先看一下它的故事脉络。
我们看一下他的故事脉络，用几句话梳理一下，好吧。
阿巴拉的主角是谁？
应该是叫杰杰克吧。
叫捷克还是什么的，反正呃。
是一个。
残疾的。
退伍兵。
对吧一个残疾的退伍兵。首先。
是他的。
起始的身份。
然后呢。
卷入的一个什么事儿呢？
搞科研。
哎，他对科学一窍不通，但是他进入了一个。
但是他进入了一个科研队。
是为什么会进入这个科研队呢？顶替死去的双胞胎哥哥。
顶替死去的双胞胎哥哥去了一个科研队。
这个科研队是个什么科研队呢？
构建这个世界，在遥远的。
潘多拉星球P星。
在遥远的P星。
那个奇幻的世界，对吧？
有这么。
首先有那个那个那个外星人，好像是叫娜。
纳美人吧，就大男人4米多高那个大男人，纳美人。
原住民是那个僻青的原住民，人家生活在那儿。然后呢，咱们地球呢去了一个。
公司对吧？叫啥公司，我忘了，反正the company人家叫就一个公司。
去这个屁星上采矿。
一种反正什么能量原石之类，反正就是采矿特别值钱。采矿。然后这个公司呢分成这么两波势力。因为采矿要跟这个纳美人呢。
这个这个这个这个。
呃，抢地盘，那人家的地儿啊。
所以这个公司呢分成两派，两股势力，一股势力呢是科研队。
这个科研队呢有个什么方法呢？就造出一个大男人。然后呢，我们人呢人用精神精神这个这个控制这个大男人，或者是说叫穿越进这个大男人的身体，然后呢去跟纳美人去。
聊这个事儿，去沟通，去套近乎。
或者是去去谈判，就是用和平方式谈判组合的。
就这么一波人。
然后呢，公司另外还有。
雇佣兵。
有雇佣兵。
就是marel负责战斗的这帮人呢主张。
强拆。
常拆啊。
然后就是主战嘛。
主站的。
公司呢分成这么两股势力。
然后他一个残疾的退伍兵顶替哥哥来到科研队，很明显。他。
他。
来到这个星球之后，加入了这一股势力，对不对？然后这一股势力呢。
主张和平谈判跟纳美星人。
方法是什么嘞？就是让他穿越到那个蓝大他们不是造出来那个跟纳美星人一模一样的大蓝人大身体吗？穿越到那个身体里面去融入纳美星这个部落成为他们的一员。
然后跟他们和平竞谈吧。
但是呢雇佣兵。
这边。
呃，主张强拆主战。
就贿赂他，因为他是个他有个缺陷，先天缺陷，双腿残疾。但是呢做手术是可以治好的，只不过要花很多钱。这帮人呢就给他钱，说，你去帮我们打探纳美星人的。
消息比如说防守的位置呀，核心矿石的所在呀。
就是你给我们报告。
然后呢，这个。
这个这主站的这一派有个上校嘛，主站这派有个上校。
这上校就说我你这个腿呢，我给你治，所以呢他相当于是加入了科研队，但是呢为这个主战的这一边儿。
做间谍。
做间谍，然后呢融入。
纳美人这一边。
然后接下来的故事发展就是他一步一步的。
融入了。
那没人，你别看他是个瘸子，但是他穿上他精神穿越到那个他们做的那个蓝色的大身体，4米多的大身体以后，他就开始发挥他的优势了。他的优势是什么？
这个退伍兵啊，他是个那个那个海军陆战队的退伍兵啊，他就比起其他科学家来说，他就他比起其他科学家的劣势是科学知识差点意思，但是他有优势啊，他能跑能跳能打。
所以呢他迅速的融入了纳美星人，获得了信任，甚至甚至还谈了个对象，跟那个4米多高大蓝人那个那个部落首领的。
规女。
谈了个对象呃，都发生实质关系了。
那就是完全融入了，彻底融入了不能再融入了是吧？彻底融入进纳美星人。然后呢，当然他不是间谍嘛？他要把这个信息。
反馈给这个这个。
强拆的这个上校。
导致什么呢？导致这个这一伙兵这一伙就是大反派就攻击纳美人。
攻击大没人。
用他提供的信息攻击腊美人。但是呢在这个时候，我们的男主角因为爱情也好。
因为自己的。
呃，灵魂蜕变也好。
意识到。
他需要站在纳美人这一边，所以他跳反在这个时候跳反站在纳美人这一边，带领纳美人。
打退了雇佣兵，赶走了人类。
保护了纳美人的家园，最后甚至成为了纳美人的。
1元。
不光是议员，最后甚至都是成为了魅影骑士，成为了部落首领。
就彻底融入进去了。
就是这么一个故事就是这么一个故事。
我们说你看一个3个小时的电影，这个电影长达3个小时。我们其实用几句话就能说清楚，就能把股价说清楚。
这其实就是我说的编剧拉片的第一步。
编剧拉片的第一步就是这个结构。
其实就是股价。
股价。
是最重要。
这股价什么叫股价啊？
低一你的设定。
你咋设定的这个是关于你的股价的最重要的一块，然后就是对抗，就谁跟谁对抗。
我们现在这个片子的设定啊，首先一个地球人，男主是地球人，残疾的地球人。
为什么设定残疾？我们来看它设定方面都有哪些漂亮的地方啊。
为什么是一个残疾的？
他有缺陷呀。
而且这个这个缺陷是是它的原始动力。
他就是想要治自己的腿才参加这次任务的，也就是因为他迫切的想要站起来，想要一双腿，他才被收买了。
对不对？这个就成为了它的缺陷、命门和原始动力。所以这个设定很有用。
然后他又是个退伍兵。
这是个什么设定？
能力设定它后面要很有战斗力。
对吧很能打。
然后这个这个成为一个野纳美星人，我们说相对其实是挺挺野的，就是那种有点像咱们的就地球上那种原始部落那种感觉啊，他做那种感觉。所以他融入之后，他如鱼得水啊。
撒欢跟个猴一样，上窜下跳的对吧？他他得有那个退伍兵的那个战斗力啊。
然后我们说为什么要顶替哥哥去科研队呢？为什么不直接就是他呢？选中的就是他呢？为什么呢？因为顶替哥哥去科研队。
他才有一个。
压力呀。
阻力呀，人家都看不上他呀。
人家都不愿意要他呀，哪来的，对不对？我们这些人准备了5年，天天研究搞科研，搞了5年，然后准备出发，然后临时给我们换了个人。
那当当当然就是叫什么身份危机呀，对吧？我常说的身份危机呀，这又是一种设定。
然后到了这个P星以后。
三股势力。
这个设定。
也很有意思。为什么要搞三就是说搞什么三股事事事例呢？
因为我们的主角啊。
分别跟三股势力都有关系，它属于科研队，但是呢它效力于强拆队。
他要融入纳美族。
又是一个设定，就是这些设定啊构建了我们。
基本的股价的前提，然后就是对抗来，我们的主角上来先对抗科研队。
人家不要他，对不对？对对抗科研队，人家不要他，然后呢融入纳美人之后，开始对对抗纳美人。纳美人人家。
不可能都都是都喜欢他的呀，就那个呃部落天金。
呃，那个接纳他部落千金的男朋友看她能顺眼吗？人家本来有对象的呀呃不算未婚夫，那是不是对象的问题，而且是指定的下一任酋长。
那个对抗那美人，然后呢，最后跳反以后又开始对抗。
强拆队对抗那个上校带领的那个雇佣雇佣兵。所以你看他跟三个方面都做过对抗。所以说你看设定就是他的身份设定，然后结构设定，然后。
对抗。
就是这就是一个片子的，从结构角度，我们要看它的设力和对抗。
就是我们。
主要要学习的东西。另外呢从这个片子中我们还能看到什么？首先。
这个片子还有个创意点，就是种族跨越的问题。
他是一个人融入到别的一个种族里。这个设定。
就是这个呃。
结构是怎么玩的呢？其实相当于是一个中间人啊，一个摇摆人。
对吧这种设定也是一个经典结构啊。
就是你到底是个人。
还是个腊美人。
你是个地球人啊，还一个大美人？
哪吒不也有这个困扰吗？
你是魔还是先？
对不对？你到底是个什么？
然后哪吒说我命也由我不由天吧，是不是他也是呀，你到底是个地球人还是个纳美人？他有个立场问题。
还有个立场的问题。
就是你的种族归属还是正义，你到底占哪占什么？就是这个设定也是这个片子，我们可以学习的地方，可以研究的地方。然后我们说一个故事，我们还可以梳理一些什么，研究一个什么，研究一下它AB故事呀。
是不是？
我们说一个好的片子，ba鄙故事都是比较完整的。
我们研究一下这个这个片子的AB故事。
来。
A故事是什么？
A故事我们说是外在的旅程。
就是我们的这个主角通过加入科研队给强拆队当间谍，拼命的融入纳美人。A故事上，我们说主角一直在寻寻找什么？
一直在寻找双腿啊。
是不是A故事。
他一直在寻找双腿啊。
对不对？那B股市上他找到了什么呢？
找到了全身哪。
他找到的全全新的全身呀。
我们说AB上往往是对照的嘛。
A故事上找双腿，就我通过这一系列的动作，其实我是想把我的双腿。
接上。
但是我在逼护上，我发现了全新的自我，我还要什么双，我不光不要双腿了，我连胳膊头身子都不要了。
对吧我要了一个全新的全新的。
自己。
要了一一整套新的零件，本来本来打算换两个轮胎，去4S店买了辆新车。A故士是去换轮胎，B护士买了辆新车，明白这个意思吧？所以你看他的AB故事设定是不是也是非常的精巧，而且是对照的。
递进的。
然后那个那个呼应的。
明白这个意思吗？这就是。
人家设计精妙的地方，所以你看。
AB故事拿出来之后，我们我们所谓的人弧线。
人物弧线。
耶耶耶。
也也很明确了，从一个残疾的。
愧无比。
从一个残疾的退伍地球兵。
这是他人弧线的起点，一个残疾的退伍地球兵。
终点呢。
一个勇猛的。
骑着巨龙的恶灵战士吗？
骑着巨龙的纳美星人。
部落首里。
这就是它的永弧线，从一个残疾的退伍地球兵。
变成一个。
骑着恶龙的。
现役不是退役了，现役饿了用战士。
部落首领，这就是他的任种弧线。
所以从方方面面。
我们从大街构上都能看出这个片子这个这个这个。
精妙的地方，值钱的地方，其实应该说这个剧本值钱值在哪，就值在这些地方。
当然了，这个片子我们还可以学到。
这个这个比如说配角的设定也是很有意思的。
我们说科研队有一个。
呃，首领就科研队这个主张和平的有一个女科学家。
手里对吧？出场的时候在干什么？
出场的时候在骂脏话找烟。
边骂边脏话边找烟。
他是个正派人物，他在抽烟。
强拆队。
的首领是那个上校，一脸刀疤的那个上校出场的时候在干什么？
在健身。
这啥意思啊？就是正派啊，往往是。
一无是处反派呢往往溜光水花。我在课上是不是说过这个就是一无是去处的英雄对上溜光水滑的反派，反派是优秀生，很努力的。
人要健身，正派在那抽烟，还那骂脏话，就这种设定对比也是这种。
很精妙的对吧？也很符合这个这个我们说的设定的规矩，像这些都是我们可以学的。
当然了，这个片子它的奇幻也是一个重要的看点。我们在看这是这类片子的时候，也可以学习这方面的素材。就说你要写一个奇幻式的世界的时候，你能不能有想象力呢？
对吧人家写这个潘多拉星上的动物植物这个格局的时候，人家的那个想象力是。
当时是非常的震撼的啊，当时这个片子是非常震撼的那他的想象力你也你也可以去学习一下呀，想象力也可以学习的呀。你去看它的规律嘛。
首先来。
我们说从数字上做变化。
我们说你写一个奇幻世界的动植物，你怎么写？你首先从数字上可以做变化吗？你看它全部给它全部加了2。
他骑了哪六条腿？
这不就是。
咱们地球上的马四条腿嘛？
他就。
他们的马六条腿。
他们的鸟。
四个翅膀。
前面俩后面俩四个翅膀又加了两一只就是那个嘛，然后还有移动位置。
对吧这个这个这个眼睛鼻子。
都给他移位置了，你看他的马喘气，在这儿，在脖子上像鱼的腮一样。
对吧你看像鱼又是一种方式，就是它把物种相结合，就物种结合呀。
比如说一个东西。
马的身子。
鸟的头对吧？就物种结合，还有还有就是呃那个动植物都有结合。比如说他们的那个。
森林里面的植物。
特别像海底的那些东西都会发光，全部有夜光功能，有的长的就是水母，对吧？那跨物种又又易柔和。
甚至不光跨物种就跨的多了它的大树。
他那个大树像电脑。
可以插U盘，大家都可以插一个U盘去读取这个大树的信息，读取这个大树的能量，读取这个大树的记忆，对吧？你看就是就是就是想象力也是可以学的。也是可以借鉴的。你去通过看这样的片子，也可以培养你的想象力嘛。否则你说你写一个奇幻世界。
写一个魔幻片或者写一个外星球的时候，你根本不知道咋写上面的动物，咋写上面的植物，对吧？你可以学嘛。
他就是用这些。
方法当然了，这个片子。
我们说。
这些都是我们可以研究的，可以去品味的地方啊，可以去细细琢磨的地方。我们说这个片子的当时最值钱的其实还是它的穿越模式。
就是因为穿越不稀奇了，一个人钻到另外一个人的身体里面不稀奇了。
他这个穿越模式当时算是非常的新鲜的一种穿越模式，就是我这个肉体是造出来的，它有一定科学的那种根据了，你知道吗？就是我这个肉体是造出来的。
然后呢，我是精神穿过去，灵魂穿过去。然后我在这边呢就睡着了。然后我那边睡着的时候呢，我的灵魂又回到我的人类肉体里面了。
我这边睡觉的时候，我的肉精神就钻到那个娜美人的肉体里。所以它是一个这边睡着那边起来，那边睡着这边起来的一个模式。这个穿越模式当时是一个呃人家的一个一个创造这个。
当然说也是我们要去去去学的。因为它整整个片子呀，其实就是基于你这个主角，你到底是哪一头的？我们用大白话说，就是你到底哪头的，构建了整个片子的冲突对抗。这种片子是很适合做那个的所谓的抉择的嘛。
所有的抉择我们在讲课的时候，我讲过主角在征程上至少要做两次抉择。
一个完整的啊一个完整的旅程，主角至少要做两次抉择，就你到底哪头的？
做两次抉择。
我们主角第一次抉择。
站错队了。
站在了。
邪恶那一方，然后第二次抉择站在了。
那没行那没人这一头。
也就是说，他两次做出的抉择。
都不合理。
对吧第一次其实真不应该去帮那帮人，但是呢他为了双腿，为了钱站的那帮人。
第二次，那个星人基本要被团灭了，而且你已经可以回回国了啊，就回回地球了，你回地球就那啥了嘛？
就回去接腿过幸福生活就可以了，他不回了。
忙活半天，钱也挣着了，他不回了，站在了娜美心里，就是说主角做了两次抉择。
做了两次抉择。
就是这种片子也是一个非常大的看点。
所以说你看。
这就是我说的。
编剧拉片。
以阿凡达为例，我们可以研究这么多东西，学习这么多东西，品味这么多东西。
当然这都是大的方向上的啊，因为我没给大家放片子。
很多这种我说那种骗人的拉片课，就是他可以放片子。
然后异常一常的在那跟你说啊，这场怎么好怎么好。
那样其实你反而学不到的东西。
你不如整体上你把这个片子从整体上有个有个把控。
对不对？
而且从整体看反而是更客观的。
我给大家说点客观的好不好？
我们来给他挑一挑毛病。
有些同学又要说了，老屎。
詹姆斯卡梅隆你也敢挑毛病，人家是划时代的大师。
同学们，我们一定要客观啊。
挑毛病不是说这个剧本不好。
因为没有完美的剧本，没有完美的结构，他总要就说固件顾不了那儿的情况总会有的。
总会有的。
我们就来斗胆了。
来看一看结构有哪些不舒服的地方。
我们说。
到了潘多拉星之后的这个世界格局，其实是有商讨的余地的。从剧本结构的角度，我们说来。
上去之后。
我们地球人分两拨。
有科研队这一波，有强拆队这一波。
我们就来看一下科人队这一波到底是干嘛了。
他设计出一套大蓝人儿。
为什么非要这个人顶替哥哥，就是让杰克顶替哥哥也要来科研队，虽然他不合格。
因为这套大男儿造价非常高，而且要造好久好久花很多钱，所以不能浪费。既然造出来的，然后他哥哥又死了，所以让他他跟他哥哥DNA一样嘛，顶替他哥哥来穿上这个大男人衣服。
我想请问。
花这么多钱造这么一身大蓝皮的意义是什么？
如果说是为了伪装成腊美星人混进去，那么你不能暴露身份。
你明白我意思吧？你必须得是穿上这身蓝衣服以后，悄悄无声息声息的潜浮进娜美星娜美人当中。然后人家唉。
只是觉得你是个陌生人，但并不知道你是个地球人啊。
对不对？
然后你跟着他们，你就可以比如说你是一个迷路的一个青年，对吧？跟着人家吃，跟着人家喝，然后大探人家的消息。
你这才叫潜伏，这才叫间谍呀。
在在咱们的片子里面不是的呀。
阿凡达里面。
他们就是以地球人使者的身份穿着大顽皮进入部落的呀。
部落的人是知道他们是地球人的呀，一来就那哎呀味不对是吧？地球人的味儿知道他们是地球人的，他们也没有遮掩。
所以你说他穿这身大蓝皮，花这么多钱到底为了啥？
我在看这个片子的时候啊，我当时以给自己圆一下逻辑，我就说可能是因为这个星球上的。
气体我们人类无法呼吸，你必须穿着那身大蓝皮才能自由的呼吸呀。后来。
地球人带着氧气面罩在外面打了好久，完全没有不适应呀，完全可以用氧气面罩解决呀。
对不对？
所以说穿这身大蓝皮的意义到底是什么？
没有发挥出来。
所以我认为在这里啊。
从我们就从剧本的角度啊。
就从如果这个剧本是我们写，我们写一个人一个地球人到外太空去执行任务，穿的身大蓝体，那么我们就认应该让他潜伏。
让他靠自身伪装，潜伏到。
这个部落里面。
这个部落名当然会怀疑他呀。哎，这个人你你是哪啊，你老家哪的，对不对？你要编，我是隔壁那村的对吧？我摔了一跤，现在脑子不好，记不清，你要编呀，潜伏进去嘛。然后通过你的技能通过你的智慧融入到人家。
里面对吧？去观小心观察人家的习惯，学习人家的生活方式，吃人家吃的东西，虽然你可能不爱吃，捏着鼻子也得吃呀。你得装你就是个腊美人嘛，然后最后。
关键时刻。
这个这个地球人打过来的时候，你跳伞，人家才。
恍然大悟啊原来你是契丹人是吧？乔峰，我看错你了，对吧？你潜不进去啊。
这样是不是更合逻辑呢？而且是不是更出戏呢？你跳反的时候是不是也更有张力呢？你这里的跳反，人家本来就知道你是地球人，你跳反的时候，然后人家发现你是来坑我们的，是个间谍。
力量就没有那么奇怪，你知道吗？你本来就是个地球人。
我们只是被你骗了，被你迷惑了。
所以说你看啊，如果要穿大那身大蓝服，伪装成人家的样子，我们就。
弄成间谍，彻底为重。
还有一种写法就是。
你就是个地球人。
你就是个地球人，然后嘞你去。
进到那个。
纳美人的部落里面。
我们说现在阿曼达的片子里面，你去到纳美人部落里面的时候，人家知道你是地球人，对吧？那你就写成我以地球人的形象进到人家里。
也很有戏，也很有冲击力。为什么呢？因为人家全都4米多。
你才1米8。
你要融入人家里面去睡人家的床，爬人家的树，吃人家的东西，骑人家的马，你会处处不适应。
因为跨着种族呀，这不就是小蝌蚪想要当金鱼的桥段吗？
你不就很艰难吗？
艰难才能才能有对抗呀，才能有冲突呀，才能显示你的诚意呀。
然后你一个到人家膝盖上面一点的身高去融入人家，跟人家一起战斗，拉起人家的大弓，骑上人家的骏马，跟人家一起战斗，才更表明你的。
诚意你的毅力，你的努力才更能打动。
人家那个那个呃这个这个首领的千金啊。
然后你以这个到人家膝盖的一个身高去跟人家谈个恋爱，才显得你真的牛逼呀。你你要是能这也能搞定的话，那你太牛了，大哥是吧？那你太牛了。
所以说你看啊。
从剧本的角度，不管是。
你穿成纳美星人。
去。
当间谍真的当间谍啊。
这个这个不暴露身份的当间谍。
还是你以地球人的躯体。
去融入那位星人。
理论上都比现在这样。
要干净整洁有力。
因为现在他为了创造这个格局啊，首先他这个电影3个小时已经有点超长了，而且他还有个什么问题啊，就这个电影不叫问题啊，就是说他的无奈啊，因为它格局太复杂，它加了大量的旁白。
就是我说啊我说这种好片子一般什么时候加旁白，就是真的是信息太多了，装不下，否则他也不想。
他上来就是样，我是一个退伍兵，两个月前我失去了我的双，就就是明白我意思吧？就加大量的白。对于这样一个片子来说，其实有点。
有点啥风景啊？
而且呢因为这个这个他这个人物啊。
作为一个地球人，穿着纳美星的人皮，人家知也知道你是地球人，然后你呢潜过去当间谍，最后还出卖了人家。但是呢人家又原谅了你，你还接纳你是恶灵骑士，让你这个这个参与他们的战斗。包括你第一次去的时候，人家一闻就知道你是地球人，还是接纳了你。
就是。
太复杂，太绕。
他有时候也没有篇幅去圆这些逻辑的时候呢，他用了一个什么招呢？就用了那个女主他妈。
女主不是那个娜美人的这个这个叫啥呃，部落首领的千金嘛？所以呃他妈就是那个酋长的媳妇儿啊。
他妈的身份是部落的巫师。
他等于很多事用他妈来解决了，就人家去一看吃地球人肯定不接纳他先天有敌意呀。那为什么迅速接纳他了？他妈突然站出来了，it's fate,这是命运的安排。
然后他第二次回去的时候。
他第二次回去就是出卖了纳美星人，然后他觉得心里不忍。
跳反了，觉得我要回纳美新纳美人部落里面帮着他们战斗，对抗人类。你第二次回去的时候，人家能搭理你吗？你出卖了我们，把我们。
这个这个你是间谍，对吧？带着那帮地球人来杀我们，然后你现在回来请求我们的原谅，我们怎么可能搭理你呢？结果他妈又出来了，女主他妈又出来了，说他她是天选之人，我有感觉，就是就是老用他的感觉就糊弄他的族人，为啥呢？去我了快速的尽戏，你知道吧？不希望花篇幅去交代他怎么又赢回。
大家的信任了。
所以呢这个格局啊其实是我觉得啊从理论上是可以简化的。
是可以那个那个更干净。
更更有力量，因为他现在有点尴尬了，你穿着这身蓝皮，但是人家也还是知道你是地球人是有点尴尬。当然了。
这个片子当时为什么这么写，他们肯定有他们的道理。
他们比如说要保特效，还是要比喻一下。
真实的世界格局。
主合派主战派要比喻那个格局，要他们有他们的考虑，明白我意思吧？人咱们不是人这个戏的编剧，咱们不知道人家考虑了其他的地方，但还是我说的那句话，剧本没有完美的结构。你保那个东西，你就要放掉。
另外的东西。
我们说这个地方就是他放掉的东西，就是这个逻辑就是他们放弃掉的东西。
我们要很客观的认识到这一点，你这样才能学到的东西，而不是无脑吹，觉得啊一切都是完美的，绝对是完美结构。不是的不是的。
他肯定有瑕疵。当然了。
他自己也知道有这个瑕疵，因为他保了别的东西了，明白这意思吗？
咱们也不是说就非要给人家挑毛病，咱们就是客观的说好吧。
那这就是我要说的啊，关于这个这个从总体结构上。
我们能能能够学到些什么东西？
当然了，单场的戏也能选，这个你你自己去看就可以了。
我我就给大家举举一举一场吧，有很多同学喜欢用节拍去去拉这个。
这个。
呃，电影我们就说阿凡达这个电影，我随我随便给大家说一个呃例子啊，阿凡达这个电影你拉到终点。
正中间时长的正中间，你去看是什么戏。
大家一块儿看一下。
doubt your resolve。
Sees time to terminate the mission, now I can do this.
You already have.
You give me good usable intel all the of souls place Yeah, I got them by the balls with that when this turns into a shit fight which it will.
It's time to comment.
哪卤喂。
You're going to get your legs back.
Yeah, I got your corporate approval, it's a done deal going to have you on a shuttle tonight.
没了么。
finishinish this.
One more thing.
Cremony。
It's the final stage of becoming a man.
If I do it, I'm one of them.
No, trust me.
I going to negotiate the terms of every relocation.
。
But then you better get it done, corporal.
Now you say that every person is born twice.
The second time is when you are in your place among the people forever.
一旦.
哪位呀？
有病。
This is a place for prayers to be heard.
Sometimes answered.
太羊毛。
voices。
voices about ancestors.
余的。
我人你爱我。
你我让么得解 now。
You may make your from the world of country.
因们就是我们。
We have many fine women.
Nina is the best singer.
Hal is a good hunter.
鞋子狗烫头。
多少就是 me。
She already has.
I am with you now shake.
对，就是。
这几场戏它是一个组合，什么戏呢？
上校跟他说，你任务完成了。
做的很好，今天晚上安排你回地球，有票，有飞船，回去就给你治腿。
你很棒。
这是上下人家说的话。
然后呢，他回到组里的纳美人的酋长说，恭喜你，你已经是一个合格的纳美战士了。我们今天晚上给你办一个仪式成人礼仪的那种感觉啊，给他办一个仪式，哗哗哗的画联。好，你已经是一个战士了。然后女主就纳美人的那个部落千金说你真棒，我带你去小树林儿。
两个人在小树林林里边。
打他一旁。
就这么三场戏是这个电影的正中间。
我们说啊正中间叫什么来着？
终点终点是啥？
虚假的胜利啊。
虚假的胜利啊？什么叫虚假的胜利啊？
就是你的起始的那个A故事啊，起始任务胜利了。
做间谍这个任务啊胜利了，成功打入纳美人了，也获得了纳美人的信任，也把信息给到。
给到那个。
雇佣兵给他反派了，这就是虚假的胜利。
非常标准的虚假事理。
眼看着确实是成功了呀，我要办的事儿都办成了呀。
所以正好出现在电影的正中间。
接下来就跳板了。
就重新调整目标，重新加大赌住。
重新审视自己。
终点之后转折进入转折，就我我要站在那美人那边。
所以你看。
从节拍的角度。
这个片子也是非常规整的。这个呢其他的场子大家就自己去拉吧。
就自己去研究吧。
这节课呢就是给大家讲一下关于编剧拉片，以阿凡达为例这样一个标准的商业片，大家去学习一下，品味一下，从里面吸取点什么，基本上就这么个思路，好吧。
然后呢。
嗯。
我推荐大家自己去拉一下。
加勒比海盗。
也是一个标准的商业片，剧本的结构呢也是非常漂亮，AB故事十分清晰。
这里我就先不讲了，你们去拉一下，然后回头我们。
下节课呀或者是直播的时候，我再再给大家说一遍，这个你们看。
这个你自己拉的和我说的呃一不一样，好吧。
下课。
嗯。